[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
ANTONIO CARLUCCIO:
Good morning--
good afternoon, rather.
Yes, it's lovely to see smiling
faces, young, bright, smiling
faces.
When I put myself
together with computer,
we have a sort of war.
I wrote 23 books in my life and
all handwritten with pencil.
And I still do it.
And I don't know--
and I wasn't already--
can you imagine
many, many years ago.
Technically, I
should be acquainted
with all sort of progress.
But I don't know why I
love to see my writing,
and I like to just to
strike when it's possible,
or when it's necessary, and
writing instead something else.
And with that I'm very happy.
I really sort of
compliment you that you are
doing a very, very good job.
Because without you, probably
the world would stop,
I suppose.
And saying, god,
I am 80 years old.
That's why I said 60.
Because, you know,
considering I started
with when I was 20 in cooking.
And I start to cook not
because I feel to be a chef,
but for necessity.
I remember I left
Olivetti and I went
to Vienna, through a lovely
sort blonde, wonderful, Viennese
girl.
I had the possibility
to go to Vienna
and continue studying there.
And they left sort of
[INAUDIBLE] and Olivetti.
And I felt all European.
I wanted to learn languages,
and I learned up to five so far.
And that is very,
very good, because I
wanted to communicate with
as many people as possible
in the world and to feel
really part of the world.
Vienna-- and there I felt really
sort of I am in my element.
People, what I like in life
is to observe life like this.
In Italy, sometimes
life is like this.
In certain cases,
it's even like this.
The Italians, they know that.
So that's why we go away
from Italy sometimes,
because this sort of
narrow mindedness.
My mother used to say that
when God created Italy,
he looked from above and
said, it's too beautiful.
I have to balance it
and create the Italians.
[LAUGHTER]
So as we know there are
20 regions or even more,
and we all have something in
our head that somebody will--
but we love, commonly,
good style, good things,
beautiful things,
art, food obviously.
Food is very much part of it.
And so I decided then what I
could do is to learn cooking.
In fact, it was much
more a necessity,
because I wanted to have
the food for myself.
Viennese food was OK,
but you know your desire
to have something.
And so I started
to cook Italian.
And I saw that by
cooking Italian,
I could reach quite a
lot of people, friends.
I remember it was the
time in the '60s where
some Viennese people, good
families like the [INAUDIBLE],
the [INAUDIBLE], all
very famous family
with [INAUDIBLE] and so on,
but they didn't have money.
But they were hungry.
And we were sharing these
pastas in a wonderful way.
So that I saw that food can be
a media to reach other people.
And well, I can't talk about the
fact to reach girls obviously.
Instead to say, come
and see my etchings,
I could say, come
and eat my pasta.
That was a completely
different thing.
And don't laugh.
[LAUGHTER]
The cooking went
on and on and on.
And then I discovered my
passion for mushrooms.
One is here-- you see this.
It's a porcino.
This is a cep, because that's
what I do as well, some sticks,
walking sticks.
I have a collection
of about 300 of those.
I go into the woods.
I see a lovely, straight stick.
I take away the branches,
and then I whittle.
It's called whittling.
And I have really
used bits and pieces,
that they tell me that
I like to manipulate,
to change scenes with
my hands, form shape.
The food is one of them.
And it is very,
very interesting.
How many people can cook here?
Heads up, everybody, my
goodness, that's good.
That's very, very good, because
it's very rewarding, very
therapeutic.
And it's at the
end of the evening,
you can say on the way, you
can say, wonderful, I did it.
And then you cook
and you eat something
that is special,
prepared with your hands.
And your partner
will say, well done
and give you a pat on the
shoulder, minimum, if not more.
And then so food
become an entire world.
I wrote all those
books, 23, because I
found it necessary to
put on paper what I know
and what I feel.
And it's been a struggle
sometimes, because it
takes one year to write a book.
I still write them as a
crafted book, really sort of do
the researches, do
that trying myself,
cooking recipes,
and all of that.
And taking all the pictures, no.
The pictures are taken
by a photographer,
but I am there cooking the food.
Because I want to be sure
that the food looks like I
produce it.
Writing a book-- is anybody
writing or did write a book
or something--
of you?
It is very, very interesting
seeing a diary or something.
Because you see then
what you have done,
time to go, number 23
book is this one here.
Number 24 I wasn't
deciding if to write
a book about for children called
"Signor Porcino and Madame
Chantarelle."
So to make sure that British--
they know a little bit
more about mushrooms--
because they don't
know very much.
All of the rest of
Europe and the world,
as well, they know it.
But in Britain, you have
a fear of mushrooms.
So you'll pick wonderful example
of porcini around, so cep,
[INAUDIBLE].
And when was it?
I was doing filming for the BBC,
and we find a few mushrooms.
And that we needed a little bit
more footage of the filming.
And they saw from faraway,
a wonderful mushroom
like this coming
out of the grass.
And in the moment when they
said, oh, look at that,
a little boy came
around and kicked it.
[LAUGHTER]
I jumped in there, and then
I was screaming like mad,
you know.
And the parents of the child,
they came [INAUDIBLE] what
happened, what happened?
I said, well, you just destroyed
the most wonderful example
of porcini.
And then they decided to
cooperate, and they went along,
and we find some more of the
porcini to take a picture,
but just to say that
the consideration, when
you see a mushroom,
something like this, mighty.
And mushroom, they are
really wonderful thing
if you study a little bit.
How many of you knows
that without mushroom, we
couldn't exist?
Hands up?
Nobody-- without mushrooms,
we couldn't exist.
They are at the base of our
life in turning everything
that is organic in unorganic.
Have the idea?
We would otherwise sit on piles
and piles of unrotted leaf,
unrotted tomatoes, unrotted
fruit, unrotted everything
[INAUDIBLE].
Can you imagine piling
and piling and piling?
This is thanks to
fungi of mushrooms.
There are 100,000 of those
known and they are still,
the mycologists, they're
still looking for some more.
So if you really consider all
of that, it's interesting.
And they wanted to
write this book.
And so they key, they
find the keys for children
and grown up to understand
what a mushroom is about.
So now when you eat a mushroom,
think about, there's no meat,
it's not vegetables.
It's something in between.
It may be that we come
from the mushroom.
Because about billions of years
ago, the first thing that came
is algae, there they
were spreading--
some of them remain in the
water, and some of them,
they went on the land.
And maybe because we have the
same reproduction as mushroom,
and many other thing,
they're very similar.
I don't go into details.
But mushroom is really
a fantastic thing.
That's why-- is somebody of
you gone to pick mushrooms?
Italians?
In Calabria?
Calabria, wonderful
mushrooms there--
it is a fantastic thing.
If you have the possibility,
go with somebody
that knows about it.
Otherwise, it would
be your last--
[LAUGHTER] --trip.
And so mushroom is one of
the items that I work with.
And this "Vegetable"
book came about
in wanting to portray
the vegetables in another
of things.
Very often I see vegetables
served in the restaurant,
they look crucified by the chef.
Really, so they're gray and
sort of flabby and horrible.
Are the vegetables treated
well, they taste fantastic.
They're just like meat.
In fact, we have in
Calabria, in Sicily,
and in other places, the very
thing that they cooked here,
the Parmigiano Aubergine.
This is a typical example
of treating an aubergine
like meat.
In fact, you eat
this Parmigiano,
it's very satisfactory.
It's very, very nice.
So this is the book.
Now I wanted to
tell you, somebody
was asking what is the new book.
Because I had "The
Signor Porcini and Madame
Chantarelle," and
here the "Vegetables,"
that was a two years operation.
I wrote it, and then they
was very, very, very happy.
And then that came, "The
Signor Porcini and Madame
Chantarelle."
And then it was
another book that I
wanted to write about, the
Neal Street restaurant, which
I had for many
years, for 26 years,
with all the people, that
they came in, and so on.
But I thought to myself,
who will buy that book?
You know, the restaurant--
it doesn't exist anymore.
It does something for
officianados, for people
that they love the entire thing.
But leave it.
The other day I
received an email
from my editor, which is
in Spain, [INAUDIBLE].
Said, Antonio, what
about a book about fruit?
Bang, it rang a bell.
Fruit it's one of my
favorite things in life.
And I said, OK, and I started
not to be able to sleep.
And in not sleeping.
I was already taking
notes but to write.
So in the night, I went
up and did two hours.
Because what I do with a new
book, I do the intro first.
Because then I have
to keep on that intro
when I'm writing what I'm doing.
And it was wonderful.
In the morning, I look
and it's quite nice.
And now I'm putting
everything together
all the items and all the--
what happened in my
life regarding fruit.
Imagine war time.
And my father was station
master of the railway.
My mother used to cook
also the same thing.
In sort of autumn,
jams and so on.
Now we had, next to
the station, a place
where to put a cauldron
like this, a copper.
And we were there living
with farmers around,
so this small station.
And everybody was
giving us fruit.
And we were putting
all the fruit in there,
and cooked for 12 hours.
That was funny because--
well, with fire underneath.
In the night, we had sort
of a recognition airplane
from the Germans and to
avoid that they see the fire,
we children, we
were five, we hold
a sort of cloth
over the cauldron
and waiting that the
airplane will go away so
they wouldn't see the flame.
But can you imagine
the expectation
of that sort of jam?
It was a brown sticky
stuff that was wonderful.
When we were coming
back from school,
we'd have it on on bread with
a little butter and so on.
It was a real tea, high
tea, Italian high tea.
So now that jam,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
if somebody comes from
Piedmont, [INAUDIBLE].
They use it also in
putting it on their food,
like bollito misto, boiled
meat, or as a savory thing,
it's very, very good.
Anyway, I decided now that
my next book is about fruit.
So probably in one and half, one
year, one and half year time,
you will see the
book floating around.
And not because I
threw it in the Thames,
but because it's ready.
And writing books is
really a wonderful thing,
because you write something
that you have in your mind,
in your heart.
And if you are not commercial,
because there are people,
they are writing also
commercially, and they don't.
But the pleasure to--
[POSTER FALLS]
Well, see?
I am falling apart already.
[LAUGHTER]
There comes a point where
I don't know any more,
then I tell a joke.
I have a few jokes.
One of them is so stupid.
In fact, I will--
writing in the book, because
it is regarding fruit.
This girl has a very wide
mouth, very wide mouth.
So the mother is very, very
worried, goes to a doctor.
And the doctor said, well, tell
your daughter to do an exercise
and say, fruit, fruit.
So make really all
the time, fruit.
So a month or two later, they
meet again and said, sir,
how was it?
Oh, it was very well.
So did you repeat this?
Oh, yes, yes.
What do you say?
He said, banana.
[LAUGHTER]
I laughed so much
about so stupid joke.
As you know, to the
[INAUDIBLE] they say banana.
Stupid jokes,
sometimes, they're nice.
Did you know about
this one, banana.
Then there's that one about
the memory, obviously.
A man says to the woman,
both have Alzheimer's.
He says to her, darling,
can you go into the kitchen.
This very appropriate
now to my age.
Can you go into the kitchen
and fetch me an ice cream?
Perhaps you can put a
little bit of pistachio nuts
on top, also some
fluid chocolate?
And write it down,
otherwise you'll forget it.
He said, oh, no,
no, today I'm fine.
She comes back about
10, 15 minutes later
with a couple fried eggs.
And he said, I told
you to write it down.
Where is the fucking bacon?
[LAUGHTER]
Yet you will encounter this
sort of memory lapse thing.
But probably--
Christmas already gone.
For me, one of the sweetest is
that one of the son of a mafia
boss, 'Ndrangheta, similar
to the mafia, not far away,
Sicily, because the
gentleman is from Calabria.
And they have another mafia.
Then Neapolitan they
have another one.
[INAUDIBLE], they have another
one they call different,
but it's the same.
But anyway the son
of the mafia boss
said, Papa, I would like to
have a bicycle from Father
Christmas.
And in Italy, it is not
Father Christmas bringing
the present, but Baby Jesus.
And the father said,
look, bribe to Baby Jesus,
promise to be a good
boy, perhaps you
will have a bicycle.
Dear Baby Jesus, I promise to
be a good boy for one month
if you send me a bicycle.
He's not happy about that.
Dear Baby Jesus, I promise
to be a good boy for one week
if you send me a bicycle.
He's not happy
about that, neither.
He said, why do I have to
promise to be a good boy?
I'm a good boy, anyway.
So he takes the Madonna
that's naturally,
as an Italian boy, on the table,
put in a drawer, close it.
And he writes a new letter.
And said, Dear
Baby Jesus, if you
want to see your mother
again, bring me a bicycle.
[LAUGHTER]
I find these old
ones very sweet.
I said, [INAUDIBLE],
yeah, no, with jokes,
I could go on and on and on.
But savories as
well, but better not.
And regarding my food, I saw
in there before in the kitchen,
that they had done
a very good job.
And they was really very
sort of impressed by the fact
that Google offer
it to the entire--
only this house
here, yes, not more.
Because otherwise the entire
[INAUDIBLE] come here.
[APPLAUSE]